IT IS GREAT FOR THE FANS TO THE
ON THE MOVE. THE CIRCLE.
A SHOT WINGS ABLE TO SKATE
THIS AWAY.
MOTORING OVER
HE SCORES.
HIS FIRST GOAL IN
RIGHT OUTSIDE.
MAKES A NICE LITTLE DEVILS THE
HE LOST BACK.
HE SHOOTS AND SCORES.
BIG DEFENSEMAN.
HE GOEBY STEVENS.
A THE OT BY BASTION
DEVILS NEEDED THAT IN THE WORST
USES THAT THE FEED.
THEY HAVE THE LEAD FOR THE ENOUS
ZONE.
THAT IS WHAT HE DOES AS FAR AS
THE
STICK.
>> SHORTHANDED. SAVE THERE.OF I
THIS IS WHAT I
YOU MAY HAVE CLEARED IT JUST
BEFORE IT CROSSED
>> THAT IS SPLITTING HAIRS.
BETTER
GOING LONG.
HE GETS ON A BREAKAWAY.>>
ACROSS.
TIME BY THE RED WINGS.
NOW HE FIRED INTORIED TO MAKE A
HE GETS CONGESTED.